[Music]
casting can make or break a show and
that's particularly true when it's based
on a popular book series when it comes
to the beloved Game of Thrones on HBO
many of the characters don't quite match
what's written in George RR Martin's
books in fact in a few circumstances
they don't match at all here's how the
cast of Game of Thrones should really
look Yara Greyjoy the producers of Game
of Thrones changed Asha Greyjoy's name
to yara on the show maybe to avoid
confusion with OSHA the wildling but her
name isn't all that's been changed the
novel says she's got black hair cut
short and that her nose was too big and
too sharp for her thin face but her
smile made up for it
Yara doesn't do much smiling on the show
of course but then with a brother like
Theon you wouldn't smile either speaking
of Theon Greyjoy after he was tortured
as the prisoner of Ramsay Bolton Theon
Greyjoy emerged from his ordeal mostly
on skates well except for his dangly
bits next time you think about naked
girls you feel an itch but in the books
Theon was apparently treated much more
harshly with him getting a gaunt
skeletal appearance as a result the
trauma of his captivity also turned his
hair white making him look practically
like an old man
of course Theon was probably not so
concerned about his hair by the time he
escaped ramsey ramsay bulton on the show
Ramsay is a really ugly person but
mostly because of his heinous acts like
the aforementioned torture and weiner
cutting of Theon Greyjoy or when he
kills his own daddy but in the books
Martin wrote him as a real ago he wrote
he remained an ugly man big boned and
slope shouldered with a flush enos to
him that suggested that in later life he
would run to fat his skin was pink and
blotchy his nose broad his mouth small
his hair long and dark and dry his lips
were wide and meaty
but the thing men noticed first about
him were his eyes small close-set
queerly pale his eyes were all but
colorless like two chips of dirty ice
all dirty eyes sighs that's what we'll
call him and does anyone else think that
shaggy haircut kind of makes him look
like glenn danzig Brienne of Tarth part
of Brian's tragedy is how much she wants
to fall in love and be loved but she
knows she's painfully awkward and ugly
by Westerosi standards of course because
this is television the showrunners cast
the beautiful and statuesque Gwendoline
Christie for the part so she'll never
actually be the homely Buttkicker
described in the books meanwhile
throughout the course of the novel's
free and has run-ins with enemies that
leave her even more damaged
like when she got her teeth knocked out
Martin wrote that Brian's hair was a
squirrel's nest of dirty straw and that
her eyes were very large and very blue
meanwhile her features were broad and
coerced her teeth prominent and crooked
her mouth too wide her lips so plump
they seemed swollen a thousand freckles
speckled her cheeks and brow and her
nose had been broken more than once
stander the Hound Clegane
HBO's makeup artists did a great job
covering the mass of scars and twisted
flesh that cover one side of sandor
clegane face it's pretty much perfect
except for one little thing they got the
wrong side of his face the book says
that the left side of his face was a
ruin his ear had been burned away there
was nothing but a hole down by his jaw
you could see a hint of bone where the
flesh had been seared away aside from
the ear and the bony jaw situation the
Hound looks pretty incredible but it
makes you wonder what made them flip
sides like that maybe actor Rory McCann
just doesn't like that side of his face
Daario naharis it's not too hard to
figure out why the show's producers mix
things up for their take on Daario
naharis
that's because Daario should have looked
less like a badass warrior and more like
a reject from The Hunger Games the
novel's describe Daario as flamboyant
with a beard that was cut into three
prongs and dyed blue the same color as
his eyes and the curly hair that fell to
his collar his pointed mustachios were
painted gold
no wonder Daenerys fell for the old gold
mustachioed charmer he probably picked
up his style tips from the legendary
mystery the pickup artist
history it was almost like love at first
sight with a cowboy hat and his
medallion necklace I was like this guy's
Moken ball tonight
Tyrion Lannister Peter Dinklage is just
about perfect as Tyrion Lannister better
known as the IMP but there's just one
problem and at this point you can
probably guess what it is that's right
he's just not ugly enough noticing a
trend here the books described him as
having a squashed in face then after the
events of the Battle of the Blackwater
he lost about half of his nose and
finally he has different colored eyes so
yeah
Jorah Mormont's don't look so surprised
but Sir Jorah in the books is not quite
as handsome as the showrunners would
have us believe our favorite friendzone
Knight is more attractive and also more
lightly built on the game of thrones
television series than his book version
counterpart once again Martin plainly
states that this character isn't going
to win any beauty contests sir Jorah was
not a handsome man he had a neck and
shoulders like a bull and coarse black
hair covered his arms and chest so
thickly that there was none left for his
head yeesh
that looks like a medieval version of
like Clint Howard or Bob Balaban or even
Wallace Shawn he'd make a good Jorah
right yeah you're probably right never
mind
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to